news that the Buffy the Vampire Slayer
reboot is dead in the water might be a
little bit premature as Disney have a
new plan for the series welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
so going back as far as 2018 and 20th
Century Fox with Disney have been
planning to do a new Buffy the Vampire
Slayer series now this was something I
was incredibly excited by because this
is a show that to be honest I shouldn't
like as much as I do it's a teenage
angst type of show it's you know some of
the story lines are very
um not the sort of thing I would
normally watch or put it that way but it
just worked it was one of the cleverest
shows on the TV at the time and you
could argue that a lot of TV shows that
have followed it have been copying it
I'm a blood-sucking fiend look at my
outfit a human
so I was over the moon when I heard that
there might be a reboot but in the three
four years since it was announced
there's had a few problems and recently
one of the co-creators that was signed
on to do the series announced that it's
pretty much dead in the water and that
it's going to be put on pause
indefinitely could forgive me
thank you
why was that well one of the reasons is
that Joss Whedon is on as an executive
producer for that project and he's had a
few problems over the last few years in
particular
accusations against him for bullying Etc
during his time on Buffy the Vampire say
Charisma Carpenter spoke about almost
having PTSD following that time
so Joss Whedon has been virtually
blacklisted by Hollywood and that has
made making this show a little bit
difficult
do you like my mask isn't it pretty it
races the Dead
there's also been a massive change in
the way TV shows are made in the last
five to ten years streaming services
have become the king and that really has
affected what kind of shows get made and
the way they get made
so Disney decided to put Buffy the
Vampire Slayer on hold but they didn't
cancel the idea they just decided not to
go with the people that had signed on so
far
so here's what I'm being told
there is a project for Buffy the Vampire
Slayer in very early development there
is a conversation we even know roughly
what the story or the basis for the
story will be but I'll come back to that
in a second
the main news however though is that
Joss Whedon will no longer be attached
to this project they are moving away
from Joss and his production company and
they are going to go with a completely
new Direction the best football season
ever I'm so in shape I'm a rock it's all
about egg whites if we can focus keep
disciplined and not have quite as many
mysterious deaths Sunnydale is Gonna
Roll now 20th Century Fox and by default
their own is Disney own full rights to
Buffy the Vampire Slayer but they needed
to end the current project and the
current contract related to that project
so that they could start with a
completely different one this is why
we've had this announcement that the
current project was being put on hold
indefinitely guys if you like the design
this is available on side ashtract.com
you can even buy Stargate socks please
go and give it a look also if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit the Bell notification it really
helps us out and if you enjoy the
content don't forget to become a fully
fledged side tracker and hit that join
Button as well as subscribe into sides
our sister Channel all of the links are
in the description but what do we know
about what Disney planned for the new
series well
I happen to know because there's been a
few conversations with sources I speak
to while Disney are now looking for a
new production company and rumors are
running around these circles about what
they want to do with it so when Disney
start approaching people they will give
a little bit of a blurb about what this
new project is going to be about and in
this blurb they talked about how this
new project will be based on the novel
by kendare Blake in every generation I
laugh in the face of danger
then I hide until it goes away now this
is actually a book I've read Because I'm
a bit of a nerd when it comes to Buffy
the Vampire Slayer and I can tell you
that it's actually a really brilliant
sort of Next Generation novel it's a
continuation of the story so in this
novel we actually see a new Slayer now
and I say at the end of Buffy the
Vampire Slayer
um Willow with her magic activated all
of the potential Slayers and created an
army to battle against the first evil
but she points out in this novel that
actually that was just a temporary fix
that not all of the potential slaves
forever would be activated and
eventually the Slayers that were
activated were killed off or just died
and eventually there was then the
original Slayer was activated
now this layer was a little bit
different to The Buffy idea but her
mother is a character we know Frankie
Rosenberg is going to be the new Slayer
now why is that a name you know
obviously her mother is Willow Rosenberg
now in the novel here Frankie was
actually conceived by the use of magic
Willow is not with Oz anymore Willow was
on her own and she actually conceived
her own child
so Frankie is already very special
but more than that Frankie is actually
the first ever Slayer slash witch in the
story Frankie relies a great deal on
Magic initially but learns very quickly
that she needs to do more than that to
become this Slayer now another thing
that I quite like about this novel is we
don't ever actually see Buffy now that's
going to be quite a good thing because
Sarah Michelle Geller has signed on to
another big project and it would be very
unlikely and very difficult to get her
back into this new series anything more
than a cameo would be absolutely
impossible I also like this novel though
because there's lots of twists and turns
that reflect the original series but
doing a completely different way as soon
as I read it I thought this would be a
great way to bring Buffy back and
obviously the executive said Disney
thought exactly the same thing
so according to my source Disney don't
currently own the rights to this but
they are exploring purchasing them
um nobody else can buy the rights to the
novel because it is so heavily based on
intellectual properties Disney already
owns so there's no chance that somebody
else could come in and buy it
so as soon as Disney basically acquire
the rights to the novel in its full of
perpetude in fact my source did tell me
they could actually use it as a basis
anyway because there is so much
intellectual property involved in the
book that actually Disney can pick and
choose what it wants to take out the
novel and never actually have to pay the
right or anything but that isn't the way
they're going they are trying to
actually buy the rights to the novel in
full there has already also been
conversations according to my source
with Anthony head and Alison Hannigan
about returning to the new series now
apparently these are conversations are
actually also had under the previous
project both of the actors expressed a
keen interest Anthony head has actually
talked about it more than once so it
looks like if this project does that get
green lit and we do get new Buffy the
Vampire Slayer well
Frankie the Vampire Slayer on our
screens then we will get to see Giles
and Willow return but guys what do you
think about this news do you think it's
got to be Joss Whedon or nothing or do
actually you agree with me that moving
away from Josh Sweden at the moment is
really the only way we're ever going to
get this TV show back and I just think
it's a very sensible idea for Disney to
put a complete stop on the project that
just wasn't going to work and to start
fresh with something new
get in the comments and tell me exactly
what you think if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit the
Bell notification really helps us out
and if you enjoy the content and you
want to become a fully fledged side
tracker please hit that join button as
always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]